We have today a second story that serves as
a really good case study and the propaganda
cycles that are often started by president
Trump, but then perpetuated by Fox news, which
gets them into the ecosystem and generates
these default of reflective talking points
that we end up hearing for years from the
Trumpist right, despite being completely wrong
and free of any facts.
And I'm going to explain this entire thing
to you. We actually have a couple of propaganda
cycle stories for you today. There is a white
house, national security official named Alexander
Vince [inaudible]. Veneman is a whistleblower.
Veneman says he heard the, uh, the phone call
where Donald Trump pushed the Ukrainian president
to investigate Trump's political opponents
like Joe Biden. Uh, Veneman is set to testify
before Congress, which is going to be extraordinarily
explosive testimony. We are talking about
Lieutenant Colonel Alexander Veneman, a Vetter,
uh, a vetted that is national security official,
a military veteran. And Donald Trump has previously
suggested that whistle blowers, the people
going to the whistle blowers with information
that they are basically spies. And Donald
Trump alluded to treason. He alluded to the
execution of such treasonous spies. And last
night on Fox news as Laura Ingram program,
a real doozy of a show, it was suggested that
what Alexander Veneman did is espionage and
that Veneman might even be, I hope you're
sitting for this one, a Ukrainian double agent.
Check this out and pay attention to whether
you recognize the person making this argument.
TIS is buried in the New York times piece
tonight, but I found it very interesting.
Um, he's a, he's a decorated Colonel by the
way in the Iraq war, but because Colonel Vanderman
emigrated from Ukraine along with his family
when he was a child and his fluent in Ukrainian
and Russian, Ukrainian officials sought advice
from him about how to deal with mr Giuliani
though they typically communicated in English.
Now wait a second, John. Here we have a us
national security official who is advising
Ukraine while working inside the white house,
apparently against the president's interest
and usually spoken English.
Isn't that kind of an interesting angle on
this story?
I, I find that astounding. And you know, some
people might call that espionage, but it doesn't
actually seem to add any new facts to what
we know. If, you know, uh, in terms of, I
think Alan raises a good point, is this a
high crime and misdemeanor? Whether you have
one person or five people all saying, well,
we objected to what the president said with
the president of Ukraine, we have the transcript
of the call. We can all make our judgment.
I don't see how this breaking news actually
adds more facts to what we know about whether
this is an impeachable offense or not.
So if the guy suggesting this looks familiar,
that's John, you, he's the guy who imploded
when questioned by the late John Conyers when
asked whether he thinks that legally the president
could have a suspect buried alive and he does,
one of the greatest lawyer non-answers may
be in, in congressional testimony history
where he says, I've never recommended to a
president that they have a suspect buried
alive. No, no, no, but, but go coach a counselor.
You could the president do that. Uh, I don't
know why any president would ever do that.
I know lots of presidents, no president would
do that. This is for the young people in our
audience. We're taking a brief departure from
the whistleblower thing. This is a classic
clip of Bush administration lawyer. John,
you check it out.
Is there anything ms professor you, that the
president could not order to be done to assessment
if he believed that necessary for national
defense? Well, mr chairman, I think that goes
back to the quote you just read because, no,
I'm just asking you the question. Maybe it
does or doesn't book. What do you think? I
think it's the same question that I was asked
or what's the, is the first time, can I make
clear, I'm not talking about, and you don't
have to make anything clear just to answer
the question. We'll counsel. I'm just wanting
to make sure I'm not saying anything. You
don't have to worry about that. Say, just
answer the question. Okay. My, my thinking
right now. Yes. Right now. My thinking right
now, this moment, this moment, mr chairman,
is that uh, you know, first the question you're
posing, what is the answer?
It's just, I'm not trying to make y'all [inaudible]
I get it. Okay. Let me ask this. I want to
get to pick no, you waste. You're wasting.
When I tell him, look, counsel, I revise practice
law. [inaudible] well, could the president
order a suspect varied ally? Uh, mr chairman,
I don't think that I've ever, I'm asking you
though, given the advice that the president
could bury somebody alive, I didn't ask you
if you ever gave him an advice I asked you.
Do you think the president could order a suspect?
Barry? The lie, Mr. Sherman, Mikey right now
is that I don't think a president would and
no American president would ever order that
or feel it necessary to order that. I think
we understand the game sort of being quick.
Yeah. So that guy thinks that the whistle
blower might be a spy. Ukrainian double agent.
Last week I had a caller who said, wait, David.
I thought Republicans were for military veterans.
I thought they supported the troops and I
explained to you that's only true when it
serves their political goals. Here's a military
veteran who they are smearing as a spy because
it doesn't serve their political goals to
say, Hey, you know what? We respect the troops.
We support the troops and if this guy is a
veteran of the American military, then maybe
we should listen to what he has to say. Now,
this may deliberately or accidentally get
Lieutenant Colonel Veneman killed. This is
serious stuff where they are doing okay. When
you have someone that Donald Trump who is
looked up to as a deity by Trumpists say the
whistleblowers may be spies or treasonous,
that's already endangering their lives.
When you then perpetuate the propaganda on
the echo chamber, that is Fox news with John
Hughes saying it's got, could be a double
agent. This guy could be working for Ukraine.
You are literally endangering this man's life.
Now they are now as predicted shifting to
attacking the whistle blower and the whistleblower's
character to get their base fired up and to
shift the focus off of what Trump did to how
we found out about it. This is a very common
tactic that to be perfectly Frank is often
employed by the left and the right when you
have a leak or a a a whistle being blown.
If you like the content, you focus on the
content. If you don't, you focus on how we
found out about it and isn't it terrible how
this information went public that the the
left and right does this. Then men importantly
though is blowing the whistle to protect our
country against Donald Trump who is putting
our national security at risk.
Our sovereignty at risk and the way that this
fits into the propaganda cycle is that the
Trumpists will chug this nonsense like it's
being ladle fed to them and it will become
the GoTo talking point. The whistleblower
you're talking about the spy, Ukrainian double
agent who is a treasonous whatever, charge
him right away. Really dangerous times that
we're living in. And this one is really simple
to understand. Espionage has a very specific
definition, politically spying to obtain political
and military information. Well, what do we
mean by spying is just hearing something.
Spying. No spying is work for a government
or organization done by secretly collecting
information about enemies or competitors.
Lieutenant Colonel Veneman works for the U
S and blew the whistle in the U S because
he's worried about how Donald Trump is hurting
the U S that's not espionage, that's not treason.
It's none of the above. It's really important
we understand it because they are putting
people's lives at risk.